have been waiting to watch this video
hey guys Ryan right here though this
would be crazy we're gonna check out a
video that I've been waiting for the
right personal watch this with and I
think I found him no you called me a
dude
yeah dallisa be crazy see I'm walking my
rye you sure today or Ryu for you
annoying bucks
are we gonna check out the street
fighter elevator prank yeah any elevator
prank video I've ever seen is [ __ ]
hilarious so I'm excited to see this
let's see if we get a hot dude get in
there Oh fun fact I did a prank with Ken
pranks TV a little while back and I've
been told by a couple of people I don't
know how true this is but I've been told
it's one of the top viral pranks of 2015
Wow
yep so you just wanted a shoehorn in
there how you're like [ __ ] becoming
famous I think it's cool I mean by no
means do I think that's like the coolest
thing ever or anything I just I I think
it's like oh that happened well I have
over 180,000 subscribers
yeah which is awesome most of my content
is me looking at other people's content
here we come
ah
there
sorry
[ __ ]
are you what are you
oh my gosh
Oh
Wow talk about hitting that subscribe
button
oh I'm so subscribing yeah alright whoa
I would do that was great that was
[ __ ] fantastic amazing oh wow
how how are they like my big question is
how are they able to stake out that
elevator
they must have talked to somebody like
who owns the building or manages it or
something is they had you know the sides
the the metal was you know well they
they've done it for like other ones like
Mortal Kombat before and stuff so I'm
sure there's like some type of agreement
they have to do this ya know that oh god
I was so [ __ ] funny
that's so funny there's nothing more you
can say and how funny that [ __ ] was
Oman I mean it's so funny that they were
they were cracking up during the yeah
yeah one is people got terrified it was
like they thought they were just being
it's so funny how like no one was like
willing to defend themselves and then
like try to hit back and expecting it I
get them being like yes this one's gonna
be the one that's gonna fight back no
yeah you think one one of them we give
like punch every time they weren't even
physically touching the other people but
yet they were still like ah that's great
good anyway guys thanks for tuning in
thank you so much for sending that my
way if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you could
check out Alyssa P Crazy's channel and
you can follow us both on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine because if we
get enough followers she could start
getting product placements and I could
get more product placement yeah yeah
gosh I mean Joe Jose Jose Jose Luis
Louie Menjivar
yeah dude I am done watching all your
videos for three days they are addictive
oh that's not good
and now I'm running out of videos I'm
checking out all your FPS with your
friends and girlfriend you have a lot of
cool friends I like your humour the
girls in your channel are so sweet and
pretty and you fall into that category
that I just started to watch our videos
few days ago but I've seen almost all
the channel that's why I went to
Alyssa's Veronica's and Sally's channel
that are my favorite girls just to see
your appearances greetings from El
Salvador Central America I hope I get a
shout out and been able to see it in a
future video
well hello Jose Luis Menjivar mang no
come on it doesn't work isn't that the
same accent as el Salvadorians he
doesn't work come on ese it doesn't work
you like to watch the real rejects mine
yeah it does I got pretty free female
friends man ladies booth does I think
that means [ __ ] listen if you want to
get girls like a list of Veronica and
Sally Jose you got to learn how to rock
the nipples okay it's all about nipple
what does that even mean for example see
this nipple right now it could be harder
so sometimes you guys just poke you out
you guys poke it out and then you gotta
learn to get it to balance to it you
gotta learner to get it about damn look
I can bounce my boob damn look I think
damn an audition right now watch look at
that ronica cow baby come here come here
I'm trying this is how you get all the
girls I was a baby come here she never
comes here